[Music]
hey youtubers they're finally posting
the Inhumans trailer I'm glad they're
not waiting til comic-con to drop this
if you remember there was a janky
version of this that leaked a while ago
I did a breakdown of that because the
footage is a little bit different so
I'll link that at the end of this but
because the spider-man movies coming up
that giveaway is going on all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber leave
a comment on this video it's for IMAX
gift certificates so this is a week for
surprise footage between this and rick
and morty thursday is going to be off
the chain it's going to be awesome but
really what you're seeing here is the
royal family descending down to add to
land to talk to the people Medusa's
usually the person that does the talking
because Black Bolt can't speak so she
usually talks to him telepathically and
communicates his words to everyone so
it'll be fun to see how they deal with
that to see how they talk to each other
in their mind if they just stare at each
other or if you actually hear their
headspace conversation this other shot
is of Karnak now they're on Hawaii
that's where they film the series so
this might be doubling for another place
or it could just be Hawaii where they go
to when they leave at LAN because this
other shot here's of Maximus with the
inhuman guards when he's taking over he
takes the military they take over at LAN
he's all about freedom for Inhumans so
it sounds like season 1 will be him
trying to start a war with earth there
was this teaser posters they released
they gave us our best look at at to land
ever but Marvel since came out and said
that this was a fan thing so I think
that was just because it implies that
it's on an asteroid not on the moon at
the land is on the moon there's a couple
of human characters that work at a space
agency that find out about it so it
sounds like there's this confluence of
events where the Inhumans are trying to
make their way to earth while earth is
slowly finding out about the Inhumans in
Black Bolt has to stop everyone from
ripping each other apart
so the interesting thing is how they're
going to deal with this with the other
TV shows now the movies obviously don't
reference the TV shows a lot but this
isn't happening in the past like you
look at these cars here this is
happening in present day
right now agents of shield is now pretty
much agents of sword they're in outer
space
so unless they're in the far side of the
galaxy or somewhere way far away from
Earth then they'll have some idea of
what's going on so that in a future
season they can cross over in a more
genuine way
[Music]
all right so unless I team that's one
if you haven't read the comics in a
while sword is kind of like an alpha
flight situation Captain Marvel leads
Alpha Flight she's sort of like Earth's
first defense against any big
space-based threat so if a giant shatori
polly comes knocking on earth store
Captain Marvel in her people in space
are the first people to deal with that
before all the regular Avengers on earth
marshal their forces what I'm hoping is
is they tease that after the capital
Marvel movie comes out so she'll debut
during the infinity war movies maybe
we'll see more space based stuff
happening in with the Inhumans going on
in the background they'll be able to
address that in really funny ways like
we have a funny colony of some really
powerful beings sitting on the far side
of the moon what are we going to do
about them well let's just keep an eye
on them just in case but aside from this
little bit of footage and some of the
posters they haven't released too much
so it sounds like they're going to bring
a bunch of footage to Comic Con they'll
be dropping those first two episodes and
IMAX on September 1st then at the end of
the month September 29th
they'll be re airing them back-to-back
then Friday nights and 9:00 p.m. every
single week after that they'll air the
rest of Inhumans they'll be eight
episodes for season one I think they
just want to see how it goes if it's
popular enough they might up the episode
count for season two but then after all
those episodes are over in the spring
that's when they start agents of shield
season 5 they'll air all 22 episodes of
that and depending on how that goes that
might get a season six so there's a lot
of stuff that could change depending on
how people like this stuff being at the
end of the week I do like it being
spread out a little bit more being on
Tuesday nights with all the other comic
book shows was kind of a nightmare
trying to do videos for everything so
hopefully everybody finds at least one
of my inhuman videos before then so that
they know this is moving to Fridays but
they'll probably do is screen the first
episode of Comic Con so I'll post a
non-spoilery review they did the same
thing with the flash a couple years ago
every year there's a couple new comic
book TV shows that they dropped the
first episode for at Comic Con
the only real special effects that we've
seen for this so far are actually
lockjaw everything else has been
practical so I'm interested to see how
they handle the deuces hair because that
seems like a pretty big CG effect how
they're going to deal with black both
scream if they can do an okay job with
black Canary's sonic scream effect on
arrow on a
much lower budget than in humans which
has a bunch more money to spend
should probably look a lot better if you
remember all the ghostwriter stuff think
about how good that look they actually
did a really good job with Ghost Rider
on agents of shield
I don't envy you
I was going to say the same to you
[Music]
that's the good thing about Marvel TV is
that they get to piggyback on all the
cool effects that they develop for the
movies so they've those crazy technology
[Music]
oh mama I come to bargain well let me
know what you guys think about all this
there's going to be a lot of Marvel TV
coming to Comic Con because defenders is
dropping after Comic Con so there's all
the Netflix stuff that's coming -
they'll be talking about Punisher
because that series is also dropping
later this year there's all the movie
stuff that's happening and I'm going to
be working on an Avengers infinity war
video next there's a whole bunch of new
spider-man phase 4 info that they've
been dropping and we got our first look
at Aaron man's new armor for infinity
war I'll try to break up the important
stuff and get through it as fast as
possible so I'll just update the video
schedule as I post new videos
congratulations to chaos legion you're
the first spider-man giveaway winner
please private message me so I can get
your contact details so while you wait
for new Marvel you can click here for
that leaked version of the Inhumans
trailer it's a little bit longer and you
can click here for my non-spoilery
spider-man homecoming review thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight